[Music]
the problem in society we have at the
moment
is everyone is afraid of making a
mistake what
may happen if we don't do anything
the pandemic has changed life as we know
it
but what comes next will our fast-paced
lives pick up again
will we continue to innovate regardless
of the cost
live limes profit driven
and globally connected
or has this pandemic sparked
irreplicable change
how will we live in the future after the
pandemic
hello and welcome to dw's coveted 19
special i'm stephen beardsley in berlin
well this week we're taking a look ahead
at life after the pandemic
from what it means for cities to
economies and even nutrition
a recent study has linked higher obesity
rates with higher covet death rates
the world obesity federation report says
covet death rates were 10 times higher
in countries where the population was on
average overweight
further almost 90 percent of cover
deaths occurred in countries with high
obesity rates
the report calls for people living with
obesity to have priority access to
vaccines
meanwhile the pandemic itself has
increased hunger and malnutrition around
parts of the world
take brazil for the first time a
whopping half of brazilians don't have
access to safe and nutritious food
that's according to ready pinson a local
food research group
lines are swelling by the day at soup
kitchens and food distribution points in
the country
experts say the sharp increase in food
insecurity
is due to job losses caused by the
pandemic
pauline shielbeck is assistant professor
at the london school of hygiene and
tropical medicine and she joins me from
london
paulina is good to have you on the show
what has the pandemic taught us about
past choices when it comes to nutrition
the pandemic has taught us that
that disruption or disruptive events in
in our lifestyle do lead to uh changes
in in
the foods that we eat and the choices
that we make uh so initial data shows
that
uh people certainly have changed their
diets in a pandemic
for the better and and worse as well for
some people that improved their diets
and for others it made their diets uh
worse
uh and what exactly that is so did it
was it that because they spent more time
at home because was it because
other things in the supermarket were on
offer
or they had more time to uh to cook
their meals for example
we don't exactly know yet but diets have
certainly changed
do you think that some of those obesity
rates we mentioned just previously that
that
may lead some people to rethink um
perhaps the way they're eating
does it give people time during the
pandemic what is it that makes people
have a rethink
um i think time is certainly uh
an issue uh there and what might be
really interesting is to see
uh to kind of isolate that uh group of
people that
uh started eating better started eating
uh more fruits and vegetables and
and and remember this comes in a um
in a food system where um or in a world
where
a very small proportion of people
actually adhere to
uh sufficient fruit and vegetables as uh
for the different guidelines in in
countries or by the who
um quite a small percentage adheres to
to that and you see that in a pandemic a
proportion of people have
very much increased their consumption of
healthy foods such as fruits and
vegetables and legumes
and reduced unhealthy foods whereas
others didn't so what would be really
important
and a kind of a lesson that we can take
out of the
the pandemic when going forwards in
terms of food systems and diets for the
future
is to see what were those barriers that
were
removed by the pandemic for these people
that led to these improvements of their
of their diets and can we use that to to
to learn a little bit
about what sort of leverage points we
have in the food system in supermarkets
in homes of people in
uh perhaps even further skills on how to
cook certain foods from
from scratch that would remove those
barriers for others as well so that they
could improve on their diets as well
it sounds like you believe that some of
these changed habits whether good or bad
could stay beyond the pandemic yes
absolutely i think people
uh certainly and then again we're
talking a little bit more about the
group that
uh experience an improvement of their
their diet
might also be the ones that kind of got
a little bit more in touch with
um uh what they're actually eating on a
on a
daily basis so there's less um running
out of the office going to the
supermarket and buy a ready-to-eat meal
and there's more uh cooking
from scratch so um you will be more
aware than
naturally how much salt goes in there uh
oils fats etc
and uh and a few more of the um
unhealthy
or the the foods that we eat too much of
we've also seen so yes
sorry i just want to say we've also seen
during this pandemic that
food supply itself has changed what is
that meant for nutrition in terms of
getting fresh food yeah so this is a
really
important lesson and and something that
perhaps some
uh some scientists have been uh warning
about for a while but our food system is
really quite
um uh fragile uh you see it in the uk
i'm most familiar with
the environment here but certainly also
in other countries in europe and in fact
actually everywhere uh globally and what
we see
is that um most countries also have um
uh they they have uh food stocks for
only a few days you very much dependent
on
other countries once the board is closed
that that really poses a problem to
um to stock supermarkets for for example
but we also see that disruptions and in
this case it was a pandemic but it could
also be natural disaster climate change
uh civil unrest in the that we're
sourcing from
uh that that would um uh could certainly
lead to
uh all the southern products not being
available in a supermarket or prices
going up
um and especially uh fruits and
vegetables
we do get them often from uh
countries that are vulnerable to to
these types of disruption
and that could ultimately lead for
example to increase prices of fruits and
vegetables in new supermarkets which
naturally then would uh
disproportionately
affect those that struggle a little bit
in buying their daily supermarket
i was gonna say that i'm sorry i was
just gonna say that the brexit also
apparently the uk has obviously been
changing some of those supply lines
as well i just want to ask how can we
better plan
food supply lines when we know what
we've known from the pandemic and from
brexit for example are there any lessons
there
yes absolutely i think mapping out uh
where everything is currently uh coming
from how much of that is for example
domestically
uh produced what sort of like um
storage and stocks do we uh do do we
have and are there certain pivotal
uh foods or food groups that are
particularly
um vulnerable or non-resilient in that
in that sense and and is there ways how
to inform
uh the consumers but also the producers
about these vulnerabilities and and see
how perhaps there are some substitutions
to make that to make food systems much
more
sustainable and make sure that the
supply is is resilient
really quick could it could it mean more
growing locally for example instead of
importing stuff yeah absolutely like
and especially because uh in a more
sustainable world we would be looking at
improving our uh plant-based food
consumption
um anyway so uh
so that would we would need to find ways
um to source uh these foods which could
be
um locally uh not to say that trade with
um lower income countries or so is a bad
thing per se of course their gdps depend
on on export with
countries in the global north as well
but certainly
um looking at ways how to minimize the
externalities for
for health but also for the environment
is certainly something that we could
um improve upon we'll have to leave it
there pauline shelby thank you very much
london school of hygiene and tropical
medicine
over to our science correspondent derek
williams now with a question that goes
straight to the gut
you hear a lot about the microbiome in
health what is it
and why is it so important
[Music]
the term microbiome describes the
entirety
of the microbial community that inhabits
an organism like a human it's made up
of a huge number of microorganisms
even conservative estimates say that
there are more
microbes living in or on you
then there are cells in your entire body
carrying your own
dna but because most microbes are much
smaller than body cells
if you put every one of them in your
microbiome on a scale
it'd only weigh a couple of kilos with
with most of the microbes
coming from the gut the average human
is home to over 10 000
microbial species many of which play for
example
vital roles in digestion and
over the last half a century scientists
have discovered that the makeup
and the balance of those species in an
individual's microbiome plays
a fundamental role in health and and can
be linked to to many medical conditions
just look for instance at a recent
large-scale study on
aging and the microbiome the authors
found
that in the elderly reduced populations
of common bacterial species in the gut
were associated with
overall better health aging people whose
bacterial balance remained more static
over time
didn't live as long on average although
it's
really tough to to clarify
cause and effect in a system as complex
as as the human microbiome links
to both health and illness have been
established in fields from
from allergy science to to
cardiovascular disease
to to neurological disorders like like
alzheimer's
it'll take a lot more research though to
pin down exactly in what ways
it's important to specific health issues
but
many common diseases might one day soon
be treated by tweaking a patient's
microbiome
[Music]
our science expert derek williams there
that's it for our show today thanks for
watching as always
stay safe and we'll see you again soon
[Music]
you